hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar advancing astrocyte research
with novel tools for characterization
isolation and cultivation I am a shell
action of labyrinthine I'll be your
moderator for today's events today's
educational web seminar is presented by
the mappers and brought to you by
Melanie biotech to learn more about our
sponsor please visit www.hp.com/recycle
Reba Ginn I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble singing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker now in
John Blatt the senior project manager
and group leader of Neuroscience at
Milton biotech
for the complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen now let me now
begin her presentation
so welcome everybody to our webinar
about advancing exercise research with
novel tools for characterization
isolation and cultivation
we will talk today about the anti class
and antioxidant Abadi as well so these
are the first antibodies which allow for
a specific detection of living
astrocytes we will first show you how
the antibodies were generated and then
go into the details for the
characterization of both anybody's
afterwards
ruphylin will introduce different
workflows including tissue dissociation
and separation of neonatal and the diet
exercise and then talk about some
downstream applications of isolated
ester sites in addition we will
introduce you into the analysis and
separation of a dive newest stem cells
which is the rare type of cells that
shows Estoril site characteristics
so the anti-claus anybody was the first
antibody that allows for specific
detection and separation of living
exercise as it detects an extracellular
epitope of the glutamate transporter
class which is also called ei 81 we call
this antibody also X of 1 which means s
2 side cells surface antigen 1
his second antibody that was generated
was the antioxidant Abadi this antibody
was generated in red and has the isotype
red IgG to be when the anybody was
generated the official name of the
target was not known and therefore it
was called anti-access too but in the
meanwhile we know now that the antibody
detects the ATP 1 B 2 which is the
sodium potassium transporting ATP a
subunit beta 2
both anybody's were generated by
immunization for the class specific
antibody trance techniques expressing
class were generated and serve as
immunity the class knockout mice were
immunized several times with these
transects and then the lymph nodes were
isolated from the animals and fused with
myeloma cells the residing myeloma cell
clones were then screamed for that
specific last antigen recognition and
then the positive clones were expanded
and sub cloned also the antioxidant was
generated by immunization and in this
case G FFP positive cells that we
isolated from V FFPE GFP mice were used
for immunization and Redfern unite so
now we come to the characterization of
for antibodies in this slide to see
immunohistochemical staining of a
sagittal plane section of p1 whitehead
mice with the antique last antibody in a
MP
so in that case plus communal activity
was detected throughout the whole brain
but in contrast no staining was observed
in brain sections derived from class
knockout mice as you see you see so it
was also investigated whether the
antibody can be used for labeling of
living astrocytes that flow cytometry
that you see in D and E and you see
indeed that a clear class positive
population was detected in case of the
white side mice whereas no signal was
obtained in case of the class knockout
mice
and we observed also the same by Western
plot analysis and as you see in f2 bands
corresponding to the class monomer and
to the diner were detected in white side
mice whereas no corresponding signal was
seen in the knockout animals so and that
means that these results demonstrate
that ante access to antibody
specifically detects an extracellular
domain of the natives as well as energy
rated class protein
so on this light the Antioch CA one
standing is shown in one or two week or
primary mixed nude cell culture and here
the code standing for lust and he has to
site specific antibody GFP in a and B
show that cells marked by these
antibodies are all detected by the anti
class antibody in seven as well as
fourteen day old cultures and you can
see that the antitrust antibody stains
the surface of the cells and therefore
nicely surrounds the intracellular G of
AP staining and therefore it stands the
typical branch testified morphology that
the G of AP standing does not show and
in 14-day also clashes we detected also
s two sites that were classed positives
but three of AP negatives as you can see
and this is because these esta sites are
no longer reactive and therefore they do
not show G of AP expression but they
still show class expression and that's
what we saw that the clasp is a broader
marker for esto sites than G of AP and
we perform also call standings with
additional exercise marker such as be a
VP asked to GS and nesting and all the
OB prc2 and GS and nesting positive
cells with s suicide morphology were
also detected by the antioxidant
antibody and that means that the
anti-access one antibody show specific
detection of all cells detected by
different exercise specific markers
so in the expression of class was also
investigated on other cell types as
oligodendrocyte and neuron and we found
no co-localization with the
oligodendrocyte specific marker mock and
off or as you see here on these pictures
furthermore it could also not detect any
double positive immune reactivity for
class and markers for PSA and
compositive neuronal progenitor cells or
in un or map 2 so taken together in cash
at neuronal cells class expression as we
read by this Antioch 7 antibody was
detected in virtually all cells showing
the typical extra site morphology and
expressionist the common ester side
markers and class show the broader
expression then classic exercise markers
like GF AP and it was not found on other
major neural cell types like
oligodendrocytes and neurons
so the next shows the unit is to
chemical staining of glass expression in
different mouse brain areas and you see
that last positive cells could be
detected in all brain areas with highest
expression levels in the cerebellum as
shown in a 2 s and here the strongest
last expression was visible in the
molecular layer of the cerebellum and in
the leukemia cell layer that you see for
example in in the image D so in this is
because of the class focus with Bergman
flyer which are located in the pineal
cell layer and extend their processes
throughout the molecular layer and in
comparison to the molecular layer the
cranial celeea showed much lower
expression of glass and the white metal
showed almost no last expression and in
the cerebral cortex that's shown in g2i
we detected the pancaked last expression
because of the cell surface labeling
here I mean that if she was classed and
in the corpus callosum glass was neither
expressed by all the good entry sites
for genitals expressing and in g2 as
shown in j2l nor was it expressed by
mature oligodendrocytes that were
identified by the expression of carbonic
anhydrase and - that's shown in m2 all
we then investigated the class
expression also in the two neurogenic
brain regions of the brain the suffering
tricular zone and the dentate gyrus of
the hippocampus so in these readings you
finds themselves that show a side
characteristics and it's also described
that these cells express extra site
markers and here in a to see you see
that glass and GFP are widely expressed
and partly over left in the
paraventricular long so in here in this
periventricular zone us stem cells were
labeled by a TD tomato by a postnatal in
vivo electroporation and it can be seen
that the electroporated TD tomato
positive self expressed both plus and
GSA P so that you see in a to see and
that he means that the anti acts of an
antibody identified neural stem cells in
the paraventricular region of the
postnatal forebrain and if ye will see
that classics expressed on a circle is
Earth that forms careful's along the mer
rostral migratory scheme but there's no
expression detected in the PSA and can
positive neuro class and in the second
neurogenic region in the dentate gyrus
of the hippocampus class was strongly
expressed throughout the granule cell
layer so that you see in g2 i and it was
associated with the GF a p+ processes
and newly generated neurons that were
identified by the expression of PSA in
CHEM were also class positive but this
is an agreement with the client nature
of the hippocampal neuron progenitor
so in conclusion we can here say that
the antique last axle one antibody
detects neural stem cells in the
paraventricular zone and it also detects
the tunnel exercise in the rostral
migratory stream but the PSA and
compositive neuroblasts were not
detected
you
in the next slide we see the cross
reactivity of the antibody to read and
human class that was analyzed by in
humanistic Emmis tree flow cytometry and
Western flawed and you can see in Figure
a the antibody detects the exercise in
both human and red frame sections and it
also shows the same staining pattern in
the cerebellum as observed in the mouse
brain section so price standing in the
molecular saying they are in the damar
staining in the cranial cell layer and
also the Western blot analysis of total
red and human brain protein review
different bands and these bands
correspond to the modern wear and to the
diner as you see in B and then in C
there's also a flow cytometry analysis
shown of dissociated p7 red brain and
clearly detected 19.5% of class positive
cells story is a summary for the antic
last acts of one antibody we can say
that this antibody was the first
monoclonal antibody that allows a
specific detection of living exercise
with the isotype Mouse IgG to a this
antibody detects an extracellular
epitope of the glutamate restore that
last also called EA 81 in short you that
it labels or G of a PG ss100 better be
LEP positive exercise it also Labor's
reactive exercise radiate liar the
neural stem cells also the new lacked
layer in the retina and the Bergman
flyer so it's a very broad extra side
marker it's also expressed on by
quiescence ODF ap- astrocytes and it's
cross reactive for mouse read and human
so next we show you the detailed
characterization of the second exercise
specific antibody the anti-access
2 antibody so the first characterization
is shown by in unicycle chemistry and
here again mixed neonatal
neuropsychiatrist we use and stained
with different new self specific
antibodies so you see here the ante
access to staining which nice needs to
show the staining of the cells that
showed typical extra site morphology and
the co standing with antique last shows
that both markets are co-expressed here
on the majority of cells but it's also
obvious that there are different
expression levels of both markets so
furthermore we could show that the AXA 2
expression is not detected on CD 11 b+
microvia so no overlap with this marker
there was no overlap with for staining
or no expression of AXA 2 bio for
positive oligodendrocytes and we also
did not detect access to expression on
PSA and chem positive neuronal precursor
the next slide we see the
immunohistochemical analysis of access
to expression in the cerebellum and you
see here in the first row that AXA -
detects gfa p+ astrocytes and in the
second row that is also detects the s100
better positive exercise but it shows
lower expression in the Berkman flyer in
its comparison to s 100 theta and in the
third row you see that access to
overlaps was class in the cerebellum but
it shows the higher expression of the
granule cell layer in comparison to
class so there are different expression
levels of all these markers
we also investigated access to
expression striatum and here on the
Antioch certainty body shows the clear
cold expression was classed as you see
in the upper row and no co-localization
with the oligodendrocytes marker and P
in the second row and it also showed no
expression with better speed to believe
as you see in the third row of a
discrete ruling as marker for neurons so
as the summer we can say that the
Antioch certainty body specifically
detects GFP s100 better and last
positive exercise but we did not detect
any double positive in unary activity
with oligodendrocytes or neurons
so the next slide shows the flow
cytometry analysis of access to
expression in the neonatal mouse brain
and in a and B is shown that 40 to 50
percent of old a to be 5 positive self
show access to expression which shows
that lion committed precursor cells
Express the AXA tool but on the other
hand or for positive oligodendrocytes CD
31 positive endothelial cells and cd45
seed 11 be positive my Sathya show no
expression of hoxa2 so ng we see that
the majority of prominent positive cells
for more than 80 percent show access to
expression in the neonatal mouse brain
as these are very early cells or
progenitors and we see also for staining
of AXA 2 and the epidermal cell marker
cd20 platform on a fraction of cells and
in I and J is shown that PSA and
composited neuronal precursors and
GABAergic neurons that were analyzed in
gad67 egfp transgenic mice did not show
a peer co-expression of access to and
then in the diet mouse brain we see
again that a to be five positive Kleier
restricted precursors are tightly access
to positives and all for positive
oligodendrocytes in d 31 positive
endothelial cells and seed 11 b c d 45
positive microglia
and also PSA and can positive neurons
add void of any access to expression
joint India dies mouse brain the
expression of AX tattoo on prominent
positive stuff it's not detected any
more as you see in in queue so as a
summary for the Atty AXA - antibody we
can say that this is was our second
monoclonal antibody that allows some
detection of living exercise
so this antibody detects an extrasolar
epitope of ATP 1 B 2 and is co expressed
on DFA PS 100 beta ALDH one as one that
was also analyzed and glass positive
cells so it's also widely expressed on
exercise and we could also show that
this mark is expressed on Y s mg of a p-
exercise and reactive esta site so the
antioxidant abadi
can be used as a antibody to to label in
principle all astrocytes in the brain
okay in the next part we will show you
now how to dissociate tissue and give
you more information on the separation
and analysis of exercise before cells
can be separated the tissue must be
dissociated and the prerequisite for
proper cell separations really the
sample preparation and the generation of
a single cell suspension with a high
percentage of viable cells and a minimum
of debris so and therefore successful
experiment really starts with a very
well prepared tissue dissociations
for proper tissue dissociation a
combination of a mechanical distraction
and enzymatic digestion as we did and
the mechanical disruption in our case
performed with the gentle next associate
er and the new unique dissociation tools
which are operated by the gentle makes
with specific programs and for the
enzymatic part we developed tissue
specific dissociation kit and the
combination of the gentle mix with these
tubes and the specialized Association
kids then guarantees for the most gentle
and efficient tissue dissociation and a
high amount of viable cells and a
minimum of debris after the tissue
dissociation
for a new Leticia dissociation we
developed kits optimized for its special
needs of the neural tissue we have here
titrated enzymes consistent activities
from Lawton lot and these kids really
give you reproducible results we also
give here detailed protocols and it's
also very important than these skips
ensure conserved epitopes for downstream
applications which is very important
that your separation or analysis works
afterwards we have your different kids
with different enzymes and they are
optimized for neonatal as well as a diet
issues to a new natal tissue we have the
neural tissue dissociation kit PMT and
there's also one case that's optimized
for postnatal neurons and for the
special needs of a diet neural tissue
we developed a dive brain dissociation
kit
how the workflow for a tissue
dissociation separation and further
downstream application looks in detail
and depends on the age of mice and the
cell type of interest you want to
separate or analyze so in case of
animals up to p7 we have as mentioned
the neural tissue dissociation kids PT
or the new tissue dissociation kid
postnatal neuron and when you work with
animals other than p7v you recommend to
use the diaphragm dissociation kit and
this kit already includes the debris
removal and negative side lights that it
needs needed in case of order tissue
derived from all the mice
so I just want to tell you a little bit
more about the adult brain dissociation
kit this kit combines an optimized
enzymatic and mechanical treatment we
use the gentle mix off to the associated
with heater for the dissociation and the
keep then includes also an efficient
sampler clearing afterwards the workflow
looks like this you first cut the brain
into the edge with slices and then the
optimized enzymatic and mechanical
dissociation is performed using the
gentle mix October with heaters which
takes around 30 minutes after that you
perform as a debris removal and virtual
site removal and then then you go to the
cell separation this takes all together
1.5 hours so here you see an example of
a dissociated praying after the
dissociation so in the upper role you
see a directly after the dissociation
and although the dissociation was
optimized as far as possible
we still see a consistent amount of
debris as you see in the first lot in
the upper role in the forward side
scatter and also a high percentage of a
risk aside and it's very important to to
deplete this debris and erythrocytes to
perform a successful cell separation
afterwards and you see in the lower row
and that after the cell deep reenter
Russell site removal the debris was
efficiently depleted and also the risk
of size so that you have a high
percentage of target cells and then you
can go on with your cell separation
which will be then really successful
so we now have a look on the separation
and the analysis of the exercise in case
of the neonatal neural tissue exercise
can be either separated using the anti
class or the anti access to micro bit
kit and in case of diet rain the Antioch
certain micro good kid
is recommended that's because the class
antigen is to type I insensitive and
therefore the antic last micro biscuit
is not compatible with the diet brain
dissociation kit
the principle of the separation is a
positive selection that means you
incubate your microbeads with the self
suspension and then the astrocytes
Pacific my true being spine to your
target cells and when you then give the
cells of tension on to Talam which is
placed in a magnet all the unable cells
run through and labor cells stay inside
the column and then you remove the item
from the magnet you elude your cells and
then you have your positively enriched
exercise
the work show for the antique last acts
of one might repeat kit looks like this
so you have to dissociate your brain
with the entity KT after that labeling
with the FCR blocking region is
performed to prevent any a specific
block into the C receptor afterwards you
label with the antique last biotin
corner gate then you perform a washing
step and then the labeling whistles and
by it in my cookies is performed so this
indirect labeling and after another
washing step you separate the cells with
MS column and to find your positively
enriched exercise in the positive
direction so this process takes about an
hour
do you see an example for such a
separation before the separation we
detected here percentage of around 17%
of Plus+ esta sites which were enriched
to a high percentage of 95 percent after
the separation and then these isolated
esta sites can also be cultivated which
is shown here after three days in vitro
sustaining with the GF AP and class
antibody was performed and you see that
you have here a nice dense layer of pure
escrow sites
the workflow flow of the anti access to
my tribute kids is a little bit
different here the dissociation can be
performed with the entity KP in case of
noon atomize or a DK in case of my older
than p7 then we have again and labeling
with the FCR blocking reagent and then
it's direct labeling with the
antioxidants and after washing you can
go to the separation with ms columns and
as this is a direct labeling it's a
little bit faster and takes around 35
minutes in this slide you see here an
example for a separation of neonatal
exercise and diet exercise and yeah
perot the separation of neonatal
exercise before the separation we found
here round and 22% of esta sites nice
enrichment to around 97% after the
separation and in the lower row an
example for separation of diet exercise
which were enriched from 30 to 90
percent and you can cultivate neonatal
as well as the diet exercise that seen
in shown in the picture C and F here and
you get nice Chi dress and we stay here
for GF AP and clasp and you see that we
have here nice layout of GF AP class
double positive cells
um this is another example of a cat
evasion of diet and exercise after the
isolation year 100,000 cells were
cultivated in a 24 well in estro-maxx
medium on pl aluminum coating and you
see here really a very dense nice layer
of pfft cluster positive cells and in
the lower row you see that there was no
contamination of map to positive neurons
only one MVP positive oligodendrocyte
was detected here and no contamination
with cg 11 be positive micro TM
you can also separate exercise by a
magnetic cell separation from the
synchrony and brain regions of a diet
brain so here an example for a
separation from cerebellum cortex and
hippocampus is shown and you see that in
all cases the I exercise been enriched
to a high percentage we are of 95 to 97%
so this also works nicely
and the cells can also be cultivated on
here they were plated again in max s
tofu medium on PLA lamin encoding and in
the upper role you see on the cultivated
exercise that were isolated from the
hippocampus and coasting on for last and
the access to and here you see a nice
expression of both markers and again you
see that there are the cells have
different expression levels for those
markers and in the lower row you see
standing for DF AP and glass and here it
becomes again obvious that the class
nicely detects all the exercises nice
you see the SPO site morphology whereas
the GF ap does not stain all the
exercise
Oh
can conclude now that for the magnetic
cell separation we have two options the
one option is the ante class taxa one
micro bit kit and this allowed for
separation of exercise from neonatal
brain samples as the last epitope as
parent a pain sensitive we have to use
the new tissue dissociation key T in
that case and this is an indirect
labeling via an D glass biotin
antibiotic microbeads and the antibody
is cross-reactive for human mouths and
red the second option is the antioxidant
rich kids mouth this is the pain as well
as trypsin resistance so we can use all
the different Association kids and also
the diaphragm dissociation kit therefore
this kit allows the probation of
exercise from neonatal and Di's mouse
brain these are direct microbeads but
they can only be used to separate Mouse
exercise
so in the next part I will introduce you
into the analysis and separation of
diets neural stem cells a dive near stem
cells are a special type of cells and
they can be found in the two neurogenic
brain regions of the adult brain they
are located one and once in the
suffering tricular zone of the lateral
ventricle and they are also located in
the dentate gyrus of the hippocampus and
today we will talk here about the stem
cells of the suffering tricular zone as
mentioned before these some stem cells
show esta site characteristics and they
also share astrocytes specific markers
like and last and therefore they are
also called stem cell astrocytes
you receive lineage so the myosin stem
cell s two sides can turn in to activate
its exercise the stem cell astrocytes
which turn them into transit amplifying
cells and those transit amplifying cells
turn into neuroblasts which travel along
the rostral migratory stream to the
olfactory bulb where they become mature
effective revived
neurons
so the neural stem cells cannot be
identified by one marker and we need a
combination of marker for their
identification therefore we developed a
kit with a unique marker combination of
the following markers for the
identification this kit includes the
antique last antibodies and furthermore
the anti-sex in b2 as positive markers
and then we have CD 24 C 45 and T 119 as
negative market
the workflow looks like this so we first
dissect the SVG by hormone preparations
from a diet mouse brain here we
recommend to use the SVG from 59.0 - 10
s busy then the tissue dissociation is
performed with a neural tissue
dissociation katene in combination with
the gentle next octave associated with
heaters afterwards we have a different
Moodle step and then we stand with the
new stem cell antibody cocktail the
sorting of the NFC's is then carried out
with Max quant title this is not multi
parametric cell sorting device that uses
microchip based technology for steroids
and general cell isolation so as we need
to a combination of markers sorting with
magnetic cell separation is not possible
and after sorting cells are reanalyzed
by flow cytometry and they can be
cultivated in the nearest VSA
so this slide shows the gating strategy
um as you see in a the debrief first
excluded in the forward side scatter and
then impeded applets are excluded and
afterwards also the dead cells which are
identified by TI staining afterwards
indeed the negative markers the city 24
cd45 in the tier 119 I excluded and then
if the gate is said on to the plexins
positive cells and then in the last set
on to the class positive news stem cells
this light now shows an example of a max
want I to base some separation and in
the first row you see the non forged
cells in the second roles of positive
target cell fraction and in the third
row the negative cell fraction and when
we have a look at the sorted new stem
cells in the second row we see that the
city 24 cd45 and tear 119 positive cells
are efficiently depleted and the flexin
and last positive cells are enriched to
97 and 98 percent respectively so that
means we have a really high purity of
the neural stem cells in the positive
fraction
so on this slide you see the summary of
the different parameters for the
procedure we have the total processing
time of three hours when we prepare on
the SVC of five mice the sorter asian is
30 minutes we have the total cell number
after this ulceration dissociation is
around two million we can sort from
around 36,000 cells from the SVC of five
mice with the purity of over 95% and the
viability of 93% the yield of the cells
is around 40 percent
so in the last part we have now a look
on the cultivation of the exercise as
well as on the cultivation of the newest
stem cells we have the separated cells
and that can be now processed by
different downstream application like
flow analysis sequencing or calculation
for example and in case of the titration
usually serum containing hombre media
are used and this leads to inconsistent
results and one drawback is also that
the serum really affects the gene
expression
so therefore we develop the estro-maxx
medium and this is the only serum free
exercise medium on the market and it can
be used for neonatal as well as a guy's
mouth and read exercise so this is a
medium that contains the max new medium
the maximum fruit 21 and in addition max
estro-maxx supplement which really
improves the SPO site culture that we
can also see on this slide in case of a
cultivation of the cells in estro-maxx
medium as you see in the graph you have
a higher viable cell found after seven
days in all the different density in
comparison to a cultivation in masks new
medium without a max estro-maxx
supplement and especially in case of
lower densities the astra max medium
allows cultivation of exercise whereas
the calibration and the other medium is
in principle not possible anymore as you
see in case of tests out themselves and
also in case of the pictures you see in
without the extra marks medium there are
only a few cells where you get a very
nice dead culture when you SDS to mark
supplement
our last slides I know about the
cultivation of the isolated news
themselves and the isolated neuro stem
cells are here subjected to a neural CSA
and such newest PSA exam it's the three
characteristics of neural stem cells and
that means on the south in Europe the
multi potency and the proliferation and
on the isolate itself were cultivated on
ultra low attachment late in market
neuro medium and this neural medium was
supplemented with martin 221 EGS and
fgf2 and we see here in these pictures
that the cultivated neural stem cells
from the large number of neural stem
cells
I knew osseous under these conditions
and for the differentiation we then
plated the neurospheres on totalizing
coated 24 glass bottle plays without the
cross sectors so after seven days of
calibration we fix themselves and
subjected them to in you know Saito
chemical analysis using the exercise
specific antibody TF APN nesting in that
case and we see here that the nearest M
says nicely differentiated into exercise
and forms a lot of pesticides here and
that's also shown in this picture so
staining of tsap and nesting as estro
side markers and we see that we have a
lot of esta sites here and furthermore
we also stay informed aronia markham up
to and for the oligodendrocyte marker or
for and we could also show that the
cells differentiated here into neurons
as well as oligodendrocyte so in summary
we can say that our neuro csa and the
differentiation of the neurospheres
shows the capacity of the isolate itself
for self renewal and also shows their
ability to differentiate
so I now come through the summary of
this talk we showed you that the antique
last acts of one and the AXA tools
antibodies are novel tools for the
convenient characterization of exercise
by immunohistochemistry and in unicycle
chemistry and they also can be used for
flow cytometry we can separate the
exercise from disassociated whole brain
tissue and distinct adult brain regions
using the anti class saxophone and the
Antioch CA microbead kit I also showed
you that a dice new stem cells can be
isolated from the mouse as busy with our
diet new stem cell sorting and analysis
kit in combination with the floss or
thermicon title and which leads to a
high purity and high viability of new
stem cells and I also introduced you
into the maximum estro-maxx medium
allows for cultivation of neonatal and
diet exercise
okay thank you for your attention
Thank You Melanie for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for ok our first question is
how many astrocytes can you acquire from
one adult mouse brain and what is the
viability so from one that mouse brain
we can acquire around 400,000 pesticides
and the viability is usually 70 to 80
percent
great thank you okay your next question
is
how long can you maintain astrocytes in
culture with Astra max medium yeah
we tested a cultivation for two weeks
but I think it's not a problem to
cultivate them longer I think three four
five weeks is not a problem and maybe
even longer
great thank you okay your next question
is does access to antibody or glass
antibody cross talk with human and can
they be used to stain or isolate human
astrocyte so the Antioch said to
antibodies not cross reactive for you
can button glasses from gross reactive
and the anti class anybody can be nicely
used to stain exercise in human brain
slices but the isolation of human
exercise is really tricky so human brain
is very very difficult to dissociate and
our class antibody is not compatible
with a diet brain dissociation kit as
this kit includes papaya and the classes
class epitope is sensitive for papaya
and therefore we have to use trypsin
based dissociation and so we do not
recommend to use the trypsin based and
Association for the association of human
brain as this is really really difficult
to dissociate so therefore we cannot
recommend to use the anti class antibody
for isolation of human exercise but
that's not a question of the antibody
it's more question of the dissociation
which is really really difficult in case
of human brain
you can you isolate after fight from the
hiccup hippocampus or cerebellum one
adult mouth and if yes how many cells
can will acquire yes that's possible so
we have a special also special protocol
for the dissociation of such small brain
regions and then it's also possible to
separate from the exercise by magnetic
cell sorting and from one cerebellum we
can isolate around on one hundred
thousand living exercise the same true
for the isolation of exercise from two
hippocampi often at a mouse brain we
also obtain around one hundred thousand
living astrocytes from one for labor can
be of one adult mouse brain so in the
viability rates they are between 70 and
90 percent usually
you can access you antibody and glass
pane after sight from old mouse brain
excuse me can repeat a stand is a stain
exercise in very old mouse brain was the
question yeah yes they can
yeah they can be used for for staining
of also very old mouse brain in case of
brain sections so the expression of
hoxa2 and last is not downregulated at
least we did not see a down regulation
and ax ax 2 can also be used for
separation of exercise from old mouse
brain in combination with the adult
brain dissociation kid for dissociation
great thank you okay your next question
is when will you choose to use execute
antibody and when will you choose glass
antibody for after sight state singing
so that really depends so both were
shown to express the majority of
exercise in principle so we check Co
expression of both and markers with
other commonest aside specific antibody
and we saw that they all all cases
detected the esta sites that were
positive for other markets like UPS 100
better to dimension to taste and so on
so both are suited to detect exercise so
I would the advantage of the class
antibody is that you can combine it with
intracellular markers better than AXA to
because actor too sensitive for
detergents it's it cannot be nice to
stain anymore when the cells were
treated with detergents and then the
class antibody is preferred as the class
staining is not affected by detergents
but on both can be used for neonatal and
diet mouse brain for staining of
astrocytes and in case of if you want to
detect esta sites in red and human brain
you have to use the antique last
antibody as the antioxidant i body is
not cross reactive
great thank you can blast and exit to
antibody also be used for Western blot
analysis the mighty class anybody also
worked for for Western plots and in case
of the antioxidant Abadi we saw the
dissing difficult to use for for Western
plot analysis so in that case we would
definitely recommend to use the antique
last antibody
okay your next question is can you also
stain or isolate adult neural stem cells
from other brain regions
[Music]
so for example the the dentate gyrus so
the dented drivers neural stem cells
they need another marker combination so
this marker combination that you
included in the kit that I showed to you
is really optimized for the analysis and
separation of the newest stem cells from
the subventricular zone
so for the dentate gyrus there's another
marker combination needed so therefore
we do not recommend to use this kit for
the analysis and isolation of neural
stem cells from the dentate gyrus
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
how many neural stem cells can you
acquire from the subventricular zone
from one adult Mouse and what is the
viability so as I show to you we can
isolate around 50,000 new stem cells
from this easy or 5my so that means
10,000 new stem cells from the SBC of
one Mouse that also work so we show we
showed that you can use the SVC of only
one Mouse brain and then do the title
sorting and the viability is again more
than 90 percent
thank you again Melanie for your time
today in your important research we
would also like to thank bobrucz and our
sponsor Milton biotechs
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
other questions questions you did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers we have a
contact information we provided at the
time of registration laboratories via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have this
today's event until next time goodbye